i'm thrilled to have this guy on i just
love what he's been doing um
in his career uh playing and now uh
talking about the ball
uh he is chris long two-time super bowl
champion back here on the show how are
you chris
good man you got craig robinson coming
on i do i do
okay that's awesome one time craig
robinson stood next to me at bonnaroo
okay uh
i'll bite what happened i didn't say
anything to him i was
you know he had um he had an aura i
didn't want to bother him
huh he was watching the show i don't
remember which show but he was really
enjoying himself
okay but uh you know you you don't go up
to somebody and just
anytime i see somebody whose work i
greatly admire or i'm a fan of
as long as they're not eating or peeing
i will say something to this individual
you know what i'm saying i mean i've
done it before
right um and there's certainly nuances
to when and where you do and don't
uh but i look at it as a victory if i
walk away and don't say anything to
somebody i really like
okay all right uh so what's your
favorite office episode
chris if i'd ask man i knew you were
going to ask me that and i really
i'm not going to do any um absolutes
with the show
with a following that cultist show
i'm totally taking the fifth on there
[Music]
bro okay he's unbelievable well i mean i
was talking about the the pickup
basketball scene
is one of the greatest scenes of all
time you know dude
the the warehouse guys were my favorite
it's just it is too good and you know i
was actually
uh using office memes to describe my
mood watching the jets
uh win a football game uh this past
weekend
you know and um you know i i don't even
know
how to handle that and i i feel bad
chris because
i know these are grown ass men who want
to win football games and i
and i know sam don sam darnold is a
wonderful human with a ton of talent
that has not been served and i feel
terrible rooting
like this i wonder what yeah what do the
players think do you think
well i think i think every player we
talk about this with greg williams right
like people were like oh
and greg williams is my guy he was he
was a coach i really enjoyed playing for
but
you know he made a call that was
questionable and and they fired him over
it and people said he was tanking i'm
like
what is the guy who's likely going to be
going with the whole group
in a month have to serve you know the
jets future plans like it just makes no
sense and
it's even more the same thing with
players it makes no sense so i'm really
happy for those players
but for you guys jets fans yes uh if
trevor lawrence is everything he says
he's gonna be can you imagine
just the way you guys beat that team you
iced the game with a 37 year old running
back he's one of the goats
with two sets of downs not one set of
down so you had to get
two of them the rams had two chances to
stop you get the ball back
your punter made a game-saving tackle on
a return
game saving you higbee block in the back
acres touchdown call back
there were so many things that happened
in that game i mean can you imagine if
sunshine wins a super bowl in
jacksonville
that punter is the reason you guys
didn't in new york i i'm not trying to
go here
rich but just playing this thing out
here's your saving grace the jags are
going to win this weekend yeah the boy
all right and i'll be honest with you
this is one of the reasons why i reached
out to you okay
i'll be honest with you chris i do love
having you on and you know
having any time yeah but i knew this was
your take
because you know i was tweeting uh at uh
big cat
uh at uh at our friend daniel who i like
to refer to him i'm probably
the only person in our business who does
that oh damn where he says do jets fans
still want to draft a qb at two
i feel like i'd rather keep building the
line and roll the dice with darnold and
good protection i wrote back i'm not
underestimating
your bears and trubisky's flair for the
dramatic in week 16 versus jacksonville
daniel and then i just let that say i
hit send and i felt proud of myself i
felt good about myself
it is therapeutic i'm definitely a shell
of a man who's
definitely very vulnerable right now as
you should be thank you and then you
respond you come in over the top
the jack you retweet that the jags will
deliver sunshine to the meadowlands this
weekend
book it it just makes it just makes too
much sense first of all i think there's
a competitive football game
and when they made the switch to minshew
here recently i was like
this is proof that they're not tanking
because this guy's
you know um serviceable at the very
least and lightning in a bottle
and just chicago the way they are i mean
they've they've really gotten their fan
bases hopes up over the past couple
weeks
albeit for nothing probably but like it
would just be so 2020
for jacksonville to to shoot themselves
in the foot proverbially
and get this win uh and and and and
minshu
is the one who delivers it um but you
know the
the craziest thing is you guys picked a
weird weekend because fields looked
really human against northwestern
and now it's like double trouble for you
guys i i would love
if you guys stay in in in two okay for
you guys to give
sam a shot with a competent play calling
like an eric the enemy and sam darnold
you know i
i call me a sucker i kind of believe in
it well
i mean and that's the thing that i was
so
um torn about because darnold is
a face of a franchise you want to have
certainly in new york
and if let's just put i'm i'm not ready
to go here but i'll do it anyways
i'm just honestly i'm still i'm still
hanging my hopes on minshewmania
bursting out but um
but in in in all seriousness that
darnold looked really good this weekend
i mean he was making some throws oh he
looked great and
if he does survive all of this
in new york and does actually
start to win games and put the jets in
the playoffs
he could be the perfect guy for new york
that he would shrug off
all of this right i think he's yeah he's
got a little i do want to give him
credit because
i think we do this with rookie
quarterbacks and the leashes are getting
shorter in the era of like
you know the kyler murrays of the world
where you can just
you know burn your draft capital that
you spent because with the new cba and
way things are set up you can you know
first round top five quarterbacks are
more disposable and
people have started to win that way
right um yes
sam darnold has done a really good job
of staying cool through all this and
i don't think that's for nothing i also
think that i think
even football fans who are so
temperamental
realize how bad the situation's been
we do this thing where a jets player
goes somewhere else or a player that
spends some time on a dysfunctional team
goes somewhere else and they thrive and
we say
that was adam gase's fault but we don't
want to give sam darnold
the same benefit of the doubt sometime
and i
i really do believe that whatever you're
seeing now he's got better in him you
see those like his best plays
that should be the idea let's get those
out of him you know on a regular basis
and how do we do that
we bring somebody in the call to plays
and there's no better gm to have that
number two pick
um to play with than than joe douglas
yeah talk to me
talk to me about him chris because look
i i want somebody like you
if i got to choose somebody second
overall here and i don't know i would
have taken
i would have taken me about 15. it
wasn't the worst thing in the world
what i mean chris is campbell
like that's that fame long family
humility but look here here's
humility there but i i think joe douglas
i think joe douglas i think he's just
he's not a guy who's gonna be afraid
of what if i make this move you know is
this a splashy enough move
is this you know joe douglas is a his
alignment man
he's got he's you know he's down to
earth gm he's a football player if i had
a tournament of mortal kombat with all
the gm's in the league he's coming out
no question um and i think he you know
his first pick is going really well i
love watching mackay beckton play
and when you talk to joe before that
draft he knew i think right away
you know what kind of guy he wanted to
infuse in that jets culture
and i think he's going to make the right
decision he he didn't get enough credit
for some of the great decisions he made
as a team with howie you know um
so and if you're a philly fan you're
listening i mean dorsey's coming and
been a consultant so i think how he's
gonna work well as a team there too
flips out of that coin but but joe
douglas uh
is a great gm and there's nobody i would
be um he's just not gonna let the
pressure affect him in making that
decision
but why then though let me ask you this
then chris long here on the rich eisen
show why why hasn't gase been let go i
mean how
how how what what point is it
to keep somebody around owen 13 1 and 13
now i mean you know what i mean like
it's so
obvious that this is over and
in the meantime if you are trying to get
um
sam darnold the the proper weaponry
around him
or the best possibility to win around
him how do you trade jamal adams
at the outset of a season and not when
there's
a draft to actually pick more players
prior to this season
which leads to an 0-13 how is le'veon
bell
just allowed to walk out and stroll to a
super bowl team i mean you know
again these i want to believe because
again daniel jeremiah
is somebody who i love as well and knows
joe and talk it says the same things to
me about
this general manager but i am you do you
think do you think
le'veon bell or jamal adams are the
difference in you guys making the
playoffs no
no they they are not but what i'm saying
is that if jamal adams is going to go
has to go why are we doing it right at
the before before season
what what what does that mean you know
for sam darnold i think you'd also need
to ask
you know the players side of that i mean
if a guy doesn't want to be there he
doesn't want to be there and i love
jamal adams game
i mean this guy he making defensive
lineman jealous he's about to have
double digits
right as a db i mean it's incredible the
guy is awesome but if the guy doesn't
want to be
somewhere you know it's like we turn
around and we get mad at the gm
you know the oldest adage in in sports
is like if you don't want to be here
leave that's such a cliche right
but then when a coach or a gm does it
and it wasn't like it was some
huge contentious thing between i don't
think joe and
and and jamal but i mean if a guy
doesn't really want to be there
uh good luck and he and he's helping
seattle win and i think that
um the window for the jets winning is
a little ways off so i mean i i really
do believe that joe's the right guy to
make these decisions
and if they're there too i don't
hate them sticking with sam and that
would be a that would be a move that
would tell me the gm's not panicking
you know and trying to just do the the
popular thing you're taking a chance
and i think a lot of that's going to
come down to who do you bring in as a
head coach too
now we're doing the thing where we're
firing adam gase and
i don't like doing that of course not i
mean that's probably happening right oh
please i mean
chris honestly uh i mean
i mean let's let's please i mean it's
it's
it's stunning that it hasn't happened
yet you know and that's what leads
people to think you guys want to lose
games
ah well they if they yeah you walked
right into that one you tell me you want
to lose games and you can't stand out in
gays this is
no no no no i i don't and i don't i
don't thirst why fire him with a month
left and then
you know you're you're uh because the
interim coaches have done this year
because if there is credence to the fact
that trevor lawrence would want to force
his way somewhere else
because the jets clearly don't know what
they're doing it all has to be all
buttoned up
you got to button this thing up and i
know you love greg oh my gosh
you guys understandably are a panicky
bunch
like you're not going anywhere in a
hurry why are you in such a hurry to get
there
chris chris i know i know i look
youthful on television
and i acted on but i'm literally when it
comes to the jets a 150 year old man
i really you know i they have aged me at
3x
because the trapdoor always opens up and
this last 50 week 15 is
exact proof of it i mean and you even
didn't want to go there as you said but
went there with every possible wild ass
scenario from punters
stopping touchdowns and holding
penalties that are ridiculous and all
that sort of thing that actually led to
these events from happening so
i mean it's wild i love thinking about
those butterfly effect issues
shout out to ashton kutcher in that film
that i've never seen but
um and the bears too shout out to the
bears who might fall do
ashton kutch is a big bears fan by the
way i don't know if it's all making
sense i don't know if you did
i don't know if you saw this or not i'll
bring it up too uh
and i'll give my producer don bowie a
heads up to pull up those
responses that i got from uh athletes
when i tweeted out what
after the jets lost by 37 in seattle
what must it's
what must it be like on a plane ride
home bad okay
like what must it be like and like i
said to all the football players out
there
um you know who are seeing this how do
you know respond to me about what it's
like on that plane flight home
uh one kyle long responded uh on twitter
uh he responded with just a photograph
of a gummy bear
chris i don't know what he's talking
about
but also i'm the right i'm like i have a
phd in those flights home man
a phd and do you know how many of those
flights home i had from the west coast
because we were in the nfc west west
st louis right and all our flights were
like four hours out there because you
know
you guys don't think about the jet
stream and such but
i don't know which direction it goes but
every time you're like oh my god this is
such a long flight
it always goes i felt like it always
went longer after the game after you
lost
but but i'm just telling you those
players you know as
as fans you get a lot of those players
aren't going to be there next year you
know
and when you're on a bad team there's so
much turnover you think they care about
anything but winning it's christmas week
the season's winding down that is a huge
weight off their backs and i know
may who's been a really good piece for
you guys one of the people who was most
most visibly upset by the way they blew
that raiders game
you know to make big plays down the
stretch uh
in in a game where you get that first
win it's not for nothing for those
players nobody wants to be that owen 16
team
one year in saint louis we were a fake
field goal in detroit away from being
that team
i'll never forget forget greg camarillo
i think it was
and that long touchdown to keep the
miami dolphins from going on 16 like
this means something you don't want to
be that team chris uh i appreciate the
time green light with chris long
um great guests man and a great
pod that you're doing and uh that's
where all podcasts
can be it's it's you can acquire it
where you listen to all your podcasts
so uh the latest episode you had zach
ertz travis kelsey ryan kerrigan
zach moss good stuff oh i love that guy
yeah we we yeah it's shout now my boy
giovanni uh in
in philly who has uh who has a rare
condition
dealing with some surgeries uh over the
holidays and
uh step up but we got fans we got
players from all over the league and
check his go fund me out it's at the
link on my podcast yeah there's a
gofundme for me he's a 13 year old
eagles die hard
he hosts the philippines called eagles
brawl let's give it a shout out
yeah um and everybody it's so where can
people go find
geo's gofundme page where can they do
that uh it is i put it on my twitter
under
uh ryan kerrigan tweet just a couple
minutes ago you can also find it
tomorrow morning when that pod drops uh
in the description there um he is an
awesome awesome young media member man
he's going to be great by the time he's
indole he's going to be taking all our
jobs
i love it i will look for him and uh
i'll have my head on a swivel let's put
it that way
hey man happy holidays to you and yours
let's do this would you mind i'm going
to have you i'll have you back on in
january i want to talk
more more about the more about the
league and i appreciate you know
again uh as you point out the butterfly
effect or again i'm a shell of a man i
should take the positives that the
general manager is the right guy
and then mitchell mania is going to
break out on uh week 16 anyway so we got
all things that are certainties uh rich
be positive
take care chris you'd be well brother
take it easy the one and only chris long
he's so funny he is so funny he doesn't
know about the gummies
you wouldn't know about that wouldn't
know about the gummies
that's amazing hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here